I was listening this Sal in the wrap-up
show he is such a [ __ ] what did he do
now well he was defending the fact it
came out yesterday
Jason had said that basically Sal had
asked for the creator of the family
Family Guy Seth MacFarlane yeah he'd
asked for his email address and then
Sal's in there denying this story but at
the same point really confirming this
story I don't deny looking for Seth
MacFarlane's email because I'm a fan of
the show and I know he's a fan of Howard
so there's nothing wrong with that
walked in the room I said Jason I'm not
asking you for the email my Trump on the
internet seen if Seth has one and if you
have so who cares how you get well hold
on wait no I care because it's the
witness Fatso's painting the picture hey
so I said to you I don't want I don't
want his email but if you have it it
would just be more convenient but I'm
not I said to you specifically I'm not
asking for it nope what is the new thing
on him now ladies what are you acting
classes hey Sal is so pissed at Richard
right now for leaking the acting class
thing well it's fun I mean I thought it
was funny they he's taking acting
classes and he was even laughing about
it that's why I think he told me knowing
that I would get a kick out of it and I
said when it's not the acting thing it's
just when you tell Richard's like my one
of my best friends and when you tell
somebody in confidence I knew you guys
were gonna rip the living [ __ ] out of me
over this so I said look do me a favor I
go let me just look can we take your
acting classes No yeah we are gonna but
I told Sal I said hey so it to be we had
a conversation about it he said let me
do the consultation first and then when
I start the classes you know then it's
then it's okay no I don't want to break
his balls I didn't say it but whatever
and I saw you were so angry that you
asked for something on the air crew
talking on what that is you wanted
something I did what do you call that
when you take attraction what traction
save again you wanted that traction when
you like ever see in the New York Post
when you open it up and there's an
article and then what's it called
attraction attraction not nature so you
wind attraction attraction I guess so
attraction
I would like to well you don't have to
now but I like Jason to put attraction
then you want to have traction yeah you
want the traction on the air it's done
now so I don't I don't want you state
what you want clearly and tell him that
I want Jason to put attraction in and
say do you want the traction because
he's such an idiot this jason jason you
know the problem there's a whole
different jason's on a different plateau
forget about it you traction yet no no
traction nothing i don't care how it you
know we're not want traction no you
don't care about the junction no no it
has been clear because howard says i
talk in circles so because I didn't hear
Jason give you traction it doesn't
matter you're convinced that the email I
still asked chase for the email so my
traction hold up where is your traction
you're not giving me what's the point of
Attraction if you're not believing I
don't care about that because I didn't
go behind your back I didn't go behind
your back I want to try Elmont traction
from you but you give him trash no I
won't be I won't give sure because I
asked him in confidence not the same
thing
asking you for traction will you give it
oh please please ask him no what do you
want me to do you want me to ask for
traction so and then you can come back
and say that I contradicted myself I
want you to get traction can I ask you a
question FG jayson gives you traction
will you give will you give Richard
track all right you know I'm feeling
kind of bad because May I didn't make it
clear enough with South shut up you so
maybe I don't want your [ __ ] I said you
I don't care whether attraction I don't
want anything from you I don't care I
was gonna give you traction
I want to broker traction now hopefully
I want to be the traction broker if you
will traction all you want I don't give
a [ __ ] all right do you want Jason to
give you traction no Jason of attraction
I'm talking in circles anyway so what's
the point in asking for attraction if
you're just gonna come forward and say
what's the point of traction sounds
wrong he's a [ __ ] he talks in circles
did you go to college I went to Suffolk
Community for one year alright forget it
no traction thank you and I don't get
traction I guess how am I giving him he
went behind my back we had a discussion
about itself no yes we did you don't
remember I said to my good look I'm
going I'm doing an acting thing do me a
favor I go they're gonna break my balls
so why don't you watch for action
because what's the traction I mean he's
not gonna come Foley I'm good okay
oh good right to have traction I'll give
you I'll give you traction right now I'm
sorry that I didn't make it more clear
giving you traction right I was wrong
alright my traction is I was wrong so
that was in traction was not property I
take back everything I said that's
traction fine that's a major traction
but you understand why this is funny of
course yeah I don't care about the
traction I don't
about attraction who cares I care
because happily no because if I get the
traction I am speaking probably if I get
the traction out of it you just put it
on ice speak in circles
so anyway Robin yeah Sal that's for
attraction yesterday from Jason you
think that's what I sound like I say
traction thank you how do you say
traction no your app tracks so traction
track so you more attraction I'm trying
to get you traction thanks no thanks no
thanks you don't wanna see one one
answer just give me one answer self do
you want traction or not the point
what do you care about nothing because
respect what about traction no I don't
need the traction in New York Times I
don't need it anywhere I don't you can
put the [ __ ] traction on the
jumbotron square traction I'm sorry I'm
trying to feel bad for Sal and I'm going
to give you the traction right now right
here on the air by the way let's have
the whole world agree whoever is
listening to this that we never really
explain we drop it and we never talk and
we never really explained why this is
from exactly I know why it's funny boy
because no matter what I say what I
asked for you'll find a way to put a
spin on it to make me look at we don't
have to do that I shall govern Aly do
not want a traction a period traction I
don't care for a traction I don't want
to track them from Richard I don't want
traction from you I don't want traction
from Howard I met attracted to you I
don't care you [ __ ] pronounce
extraction or whatever the profit is I
don't want a traction that's it
alright and that's the end of this
wonderful show thank you so